Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we are going take a collection of photos
like these, and magically, create a video
where we can fly through these photos.
And it gets better, we will be able to do
it quickly, and, get this, no AI is required.
So, how is this even possible?
Especially that the input is only a handful
of photos.
Well, typically, we give it to a learning
algorithm and ask it to synthesize a photorealistic
video where we fly through the scene as we
please.
Of course, that sounds impossible.
Especially that some information is given
about the scene, but this is really not much.
And as you see, this is not impossible at
all - through the power of learning-based
techniques, this previous AI is already capable
of pulling off this amazing trick.
And today, I am going to show you that through
this incredible new paper, that something
like this can even be done at home, on our
own machines.
Now, the previously showcased technique, and
its predecessors are building on gathering
training data and training a neural network
to pull this off.
Here you see the training process of one of
them compared to the reference results.
Well, it looks like we need to be really patient
as this process is quite lengthy, and for
the majority of the time, we don’t get any
usable results for nearly a day into this
process.
Now, hold on to your papers, because here
comes the twist.
What is the twist?
Well, these are not reference results.
No-no.
These are the results from the new technique.
Yes, you heard it right.
It doesn’t require a neural network, and
thus trains so quickly, that it almost immediately
looks like the final result, while the original
technique is still unable to produce anything
usable.
That is absolutely insane.
Okay, so it’s quick.
Real quick.
But how good are the results?
Well, the previous technique was able to produce
this after approximately 1.5 days of training.
And, what about the new technique?
All it needs is 8.8.
8.8 what?
Days?
Hours?
No-no. 8.8 minutes.
And the result looks like this.
Not only as good, but even a bit better than
what the previous method could do in 1.5 days.
Whoa.
So, I mentioned that the results are typically
even a bit better, which is quite remarkable.
Let’s take a closer look.
This is the previous technique after more
than a day, this is the new method after 18
minutes.
Now, it says that the new technique is 0.3
decibels better, that does not sound like
much, does it?
Well, note that the decibel scale is not linear,
it is logarithmic.
What does this mean?
It means this!
Look.
A small numerical difference in the numbers
can mean mean a big difference in quality.
And, it is really close to the real results.
And all this after 20 minutes of processing?
Bravo!
And, it does not stop there.
The technique is also quite robust.
It works well on forward-facing scenes, 360
degree rotations, and we can even use it to
disassemble a scene into its foreground and
background elements.
Note that the previous NERF technique we compared
to was published just about a year and a half
ago.
Such incredible improvement in so little time.
And here comes the kicker: all this is possible
today with a handcrafted technique, no AI
is required.
What a time
to be alive!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!